I've had it up to here I'm gonna start
crying
[Music]
what are we doing today we're gonna turn
our charcoal grill and we're gonna show
you guys some hex on how to take a
everyday use kind of grill and turn it
into a smoker right can we get a heat
check it is currently 106 degrees at
this day of the week
perhaps the hottest day of the year and
we said what better to do with our time
then come outside and start a fire one
smoked a big old piece of meat call me
today I mean you could theoretically
it's not a vegetable I mean I'm sure it
tastes good I haven't had a vegetable in
some time I forget I had a carrot
yesterday let's can we cut that okay
let's start with a snake but you wanted
to introduce a charcoal and like a stop
motion kind of way yeah okay
I'm gonna think of stuff ahead as well
and see if the pen fits in there it
takes up a good amount of space right
now that pans real big
that's foil just keep all that up so
janky but it does the job well the snake
movie recording has been stopped
you know what happened I know what
format
what and format the card you also moved
the grill so now that we've created a
ring of charcoal for the snake to start
we're gonna put a layer of the woodchips
right on top so that you could get that
smoky flavor infused into the meat all
right woodchips hold on forgot that we
were supposed to like soak the woodchips
and water my dad always taught me that
it always has to be at least 12 hours
that's open from 12 hours since well he
was a slow smoker that's crazy talk but
is the smoking that he did was good
though
we've been soaking these for quite some
time
fine we just want like a sprinkling of
woodchips that's perfect that's exactly
how I meant to do it from the beginning
that's good okay that water is just as
hot as the air broken pan not bad
perfect let's put this bad boy I sure
hope so I never cut it ah
apparently it's not really did you cut
it I didn't touch it
[Music]
all right we lost all the wood chip
footage there never was any wood chip
footage we got the rest of the charcoals
so I got to get all the wood chips out
I'm not against starting over so after a
few false starts we've decided that
we're gonna have ray do the hammer just
so I can oversee in sort of a managerial
capacity so the charcoal is the fire
essentially and the way the fuse works
is it's a delayed heat so we don't have
to keep feeding the fire wood chips are
for flavor that's like the smoking
process and the water essentially serves
two purposes which is one to help
regulate the temperature inside the
grill and it also just keeps it the
moisture in there so to start it I'm
just adding coals to this side right so
how about I do that shot person and I'll
just go to that every recording has
stopped automatically is it the heat
again no the cards full yep we got it we
got it we just need a new card we wish I
wore shorts today
I know why I didn't just go like here
yeah this feels very momentous I feel
like we've gotten to a place in this
video where we're probably gonna finish
it before I wasn't so sure I could never
really see the finish line and even
though we're not there yet we're gonna
get there
will you do the honors the ceremonial
shield I'm sorry it's not a shield it's
a it's a way yes already see if you're
gonna do a clean scoop all of all for us
yeah I bet you can do it I do it okay
cool you got this you got this you got
this I got three all right this is your
moment here we go
you you you oh that was by far the best
smile this is it right I have the utmost
faith in you okay I'm gonna do one more
time vastly inferior smoke really here
we go
nice work all right I feel like I'm good
what I'll do we need anything else oh
yes
[Music]